the part of this role and part of this
job and this family being under the
pressure that it's under inevitably you
know stuff stuff happens Prince William
and Prince Harry are improving their
brotherly bond
we're brothers we'll always be brothers
et has learned that the Duke of
Cambridge and Duke of Sussex are talking
more and they're on better footing
following Harry and wife Megan Markel's
decision to step back from the royal
family despite reports in the media that
the brothers hate each other our source
clarified that that's definitely not the
case a big reason why
well our source says living in different
homes really helped because they weren't
always having to talk business
quote the brothers have different
futures with very important
institutional roles and that created a
complicated relationship once the
households separated things improved you
really see each other as much as we as
much as we used to because we're so busy
but you know I love him dearly and the
majority of the stuff is probably well
the majority of stuff is created out of
nothing
still our source maintains that William
and other members of the royal family
were disappointed when the Sussex is
announced they're no longer senior
Royals quote William has always
expressed concern for Harry since they
were children William has always watched
out for his younger brother the source
said the family initially felt
blindsided when Harry and Megan revealed
the news publicly after they were asked
to hold off but ultimately they just
want the couple to be happy well this
has come as a shock to the whole family
this is seismic this has had a huge
impact on his brother on his
sister-in-law I think both of them are
still reeling from the news coming to
terms with the reality of of this
situation a second source close to the
Sussex is tells ET that it
isn't an easy decision for Harry and
added that he loves his family Harry
really is putting on a brave face
throughout all of this that he's just
you know he's positive about his future
but he's very very torn he's very sad
about leaving his family is very sad
about leaving the United Kingdom this is
a royal who's always worn his heart on
his sleeve
aside from their personal lives the
Royals professional lives are keeping
them busy busy busy according to a
source Harry and Megan made a surprise
appearance at a JPMorgan gathering in
Miami on Thursday Harry spoke at the
event Megan
did not